when it comes to modern day action stars
a few names always have to enter the mix
dwayne the rock johnson follows in the
long story tradition of larger than life
figures honestly anyone who's been in a
fast and furious movie falls into that
category and that goes double with one
of the hardest working men in hollywood
jason statham throughout the 21st
century he starred in some of the most
critically acclaimed heist and action
flicks such as the italian job crank and
war when you walk into a statham movie
you know exactly what you're getting but
not every film can be a hit others fall
off the radar but older movies have
managed to find a second life thanks to
the glitch of streaming services as of
late that's the case for the underrated
statham movie chaos which is now making
waves on netflix the movie only grows 7
million dollars globally during its run
but now's your chance of seeing what you
missed 16 years ago see why the film was
broken into the platform's top 10 movies
especially if you're a fan of statham's
other works statham plays a veteran
detective named quinton connors who is
reprimanded and then quickly reinstated
onto the force when a group of criminals
takes hostages in a bank he's teamed up
with rookie cop shane decker and things
take a turn for the worse when they
discover the thieves uploaded a computer
virus into the bank's systems capable of
random evolution the virus follows the
principles of chaos theory which is
where the film gets its name so it's a
race against the clock for the officers
to figure out a way to stop the attack
you'd be forgiven for missing the film
when it first came out it didn't receive
a theatrical release in the united
states going straight to video instead
that's a bit of a surprise considering
that statham star was on the rise in the
early 2000s thanks to his appearance in
movies like the transporter series and
the italian job and that's not even to
mention the fact that ryan phillippe and
wesley snipes themselves well-known
actors at the time co-star in the movie
the few critics that did review chaos
were mostly underwhelmed but that only
paints half a picture in regard to how
the film has been received over the
years real film gave the movie 2 stars
out of fife and complain that the
movie's occasional moments of strong
action filmmaking were otherwise bogged
down with an overwrought and overplayed
sensibility that proves disastrous the
outlet said the movie lacked originality
and concluded the equally impressive
performances ensure that boredom never
entirely sets in though it's awfully
difficult to look past the almost
laughably inept instances of plotting
within jillio's screenplay the film did
have its defenders though fermi films
enjoyed statham's performance and noted
it's got some delightfully done set
pieces they concluded their review by
writing while i wasn't expecting a whole
lot what i got was thoroughly enjoyable
and most definitely a film worth
watching so all in all a pretty mixed
and negative response from critics when
it comes to audience reactions though
moviegoers seem to enjoy the statham
action flick with the movie like chaos
critical reception should be taken with
a grain of salt after all not everyone
is tuning in to a statham headliner for
strong characters and an intricate plot
and for movie fans who left reviews on
imdb the consensus seems to be that krc
is all in all a fun watch one user said
all the signs were pointing to this
being a bad movie it is fun to watch and
the film does present an intriguing
mystery with a few surprising twists
along the way another user also had a
fun time with chaos despite their
nitpicks they loved the movies twists
and turns and while they did take issue
with some of the character choices they
ultimately said but for a popcorn
thriller this was quite entertaining any
film with stapler minutes is always
worth a watch with the movie currently
killing it on netflix it looks like
audiences are in agreement that chaos is
one forgotten gem that's worth checking
out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]